nace con un nuevo comando para combatir
el narcotráfico la guerrilla y las
amenazas transnacionales este fue el
anuncio que hizo el presidente iván
duque el viernes en el fuerte militar de
tolemaida el principal centro de
formación del ejército colombiano que
esta fuerza
y el trabajo articulado de toda la
fuerza pública
irá sin contemplación a desmantelar las
estructuras del narcotráfico de ln
del anarco tal ya
de las disidencias esta nueva unidad del
ejército estará formada por siete mil
integrantes en un tono vehemente duque
recordó al nuevo cuerpo de élite la
importancia que el gobierno espera que
tenga para colombia' ustedes
empiezan
esta fuerza
para lograr resultados históricos
para sembrar confianza admiración
ardiente a de la ciudadanía al lado de
sus soldados
la creación de conaf llega también en
momentos en los que el gobierno de duke
se prepara para retomar la aspersión
aérea de los cultivos ilícitos con el
herbicida glifosato una práctica que fue
suspendida en 2015 cuando la corte
constitucional prohibió su uso por
posibles daños a la salud en 2019 los
cultivos de coca llegaron a unas 154.000
hectáreas
en medio de presiones por parte de eeuu
colombia hace un nuevo intento por
combatir el narcotráfico con una nueva
fuerza de élite algo que genera
suspicacias la semana pasada la
jurisdicción especial de paz creada tras
la firma del acuerdo de paz en 2016
anunció que el número de falsos
positivos ejecuciones extrajudiciales de
civiles a manos del ejército para
presentar bajas en combate entre 2002 y
2008 ascendía a 6400 dos personas